[Música]
eu cansei de não ser representada nos
lugares e eu decidi a partir de então é
é usar os meus braços para promover
algumas ações para outras pessoas
o meu principal objetivo na vida é a
proporcionalidade ou seja se nós somos
54% da população estou falando da
população negra porque nós não somos
representados em todos os espaços
nisso eu acabei voltando atrás e
lembrando de como foi a minha infância e
olhando o contexto de ver que nas
bonecas que nossas atividades em outras
situações e eu acabei não tendo essa
representação também
contudo quando eu vou pensando em
processos e/ou de empreendedorismo
voltado para a gestão de negócios
a gente vai vendo o quanto que a
população negra está inserida nós somos
51% dos microempreendedores e
curiosamente quando a gente fala de
startup a gente não tem essa mesma
representação e aí pelo fato de buscar
fazer soluções que estejam dentro do
contexto de inovação empreendedorismo
tecnologia eu fui perguntar para as
pessoas que já estão inseridas nesse
contexto o porquê que a população negra
não está representada ea resposta sempre
foi a mesma
as pessoas não chegam essas pessoas elas
não estão aqui essas pessoas elas não
estão sendo representadas
elas estão operacional elas estão
aprendendo por necessidade e isso sempre
me incomodou porque eu sempre via muito
potencial vejo até hoje muito potencial
da população negra e simplesmente a
gente olha e as pessoas acabam
entendendo e olhando pra gente como
operacional
essa imagem choca porque ela tem um
objetivo justamente desmistificar esse
lugar da população negra promover pra
gente que a gente está em todos os
lugares no entanto gente não tem a mesma
proporção
e essa proporção é onde eu busco hoje
fazer algumas ações buscando mais cada
vez mais entendem
um texto que nós na população negra
estamos a gente chega em dados de
violência
então a população negra à população que
mais morre que seja por homicídio então
genocídio da população negra a cada 100
pessoas 71 são pessoas negras que acabou
morrendo por homicídio gente também tem
as mulheres negras morrendo por
violência e seja doméstica obstétrica é
dada alta mortalidade materna
tudo isso é e isso coloca nossos corpos
vulnerabilidade neral vice diante da
violência
e esse contexto cada vez mais me fez
perceber o quanto que a gente precisa
mudar esse mimo esse processo nós
precisamos entender o quanto que nós
vamos ter que desenvolver algumas ações
que a gente possa promover para a
população negra uma valorização e
pensando em todo esse esse propósito e
pensando em todo esse mundo um movimento
que é colocado para a população negra
diante da violência eu não fiquei calada
eu não quis olhar só para o contexto de
a colocar nós como um processo de
operacionalização ou dentro da violência
eu quis muito entender qual é o
potencial da população negra o que a
gente faz o que a gente tem de potencial
e eu consegui encontrar alguns dados nós
movimentamos em 2015 800 milhões de
reais bilhões de reais desse valor
enquanto que a gente olha para a
população negra e ver de fato esse
potencial em 2017 nós chegamos a
movimentar 1 trilhão a 5 trilhão e meio
mas e por isso cada vez mais eu fui
vendo que a gente tem potencial dos mais
diversos
no entanto ainda é colocado à população
negra nesse lado operacional e olhando
para as startups qual é o principal
objetivo da startup solucionadores reais
solucionar dificuldades que a população
tenha dificuldades que a as pessoas
acabam tendo oportunidades diante de um
negócio
e por que que a gente não olha o
contexto o que acontece
'nesse simplesmente pelo fato da gente
não tá inserido num ecossistema gente
não tem o direito de se desenvolver
nesse processo e aí foi onde eu tentei e
e desenvolvia outras ações que são
voltadas pensando na individualidade de
apoio das pessoas pensando que nós somos
um grupo mas um grupo que também tem o
seu processo individual
nós também fazemos de tudo de
criatividade de dentro do tecido social
é dentro de um contexto social às nossas
iniciativas nossas startup muitas vezes
elas têm um potencial muito grande de
desenvolver ações voltadas para o social
então quando a gente pensa em dólares
reais a gente vai muito para a área de
educação para saúde desenvolvendo
algumas ações dentro da área da cultura
já que a gente tem toda uma desenvoltura
para se fazer esse presente dentro da
área da cultura
nós somos extremamente empenhadas nas
nossas ações
por isso que a gente existe até hoje
porque dependendo do genocídio gente não
estaria nem vivo e olhando para esse
mundo do startup o que mais me chamou a
atenção foi essa imagem
o quanto que a geração de startup ela é
só vista como um público como um tipo de
pessoa e o quanto que isso interfere
totalmente no processo da construção de
produtos e serviços
porque a partir do momento que eu crio
produtos voltados para a mesma pessoa ou
até mesmo criados pelas mesmas pessoas
a tendência cada vez mais eu construir
coisas que não vão agregar tanto valor
para outras pessoas
por isso que cada vez mais a gente
percebe o quanto que vai isolando todo
esse processo
existe um levantamento é é dos estados
unidos que identificou que investidores
acabam investindo mais em homens brancos
e curiosamente foram identificar quem
são esses vencedores
obviamente pessoas que se pareçam com
eles
ou seja se eu me identifico com essas
pessoas eu acabo associando
automaticamente e colocando valores que
eu tenho pra mim pra aquela outra pessoa
se eu não me identifico com uma pessoa
negra
praticamente eu também não vou fazer um
desempenho de investir nessa pessoa
isso me chamou muita atenção e com
relação à a isso a gente vê o potencial
da população negra e eu acabo utilizando
em muitas das minhas palestras ao
exemplo do pantera negra o quanto que o
filme ele desenvolveu a possibilidade de
a gente olhar não só o protagonismo da
população negra mas também o quanto que
cada pessoa foi tendo a curiosidade e
interesse em saber sobre o filme
além disso o filme movimento tantos
milhões
ele chegou a site irá o titanic do
terceiro lugar de filme mais visto
isso só comprova a cada vez mais que não
só a população negra quer se sentir
representada mas também ela tem o poder
aquisitivo de fazer diferença e ela quer
mais o quê nunca desenvolver ações
voltadas para ela e se olhando para esse
processo e saindo um pouco do contexto
fora do brasil eu comecei a buscar
outras iniciativas e outras pessoas que
também queriam olhar de forma positiva
para a população negra e eu cheguei na
preta lab
a peta lab é uma instituição é é
liderada pela se o bahia que é fez uma
pesquisa com mais de 500 mulheres
identificou mais de 500 mulheres negras
indígenas que estão na área de
tecnologia ou seja nós já estamos
inseridos nesse ecossistema no entanto
nós não somos representados
nós temos também o livro gênios da
humanidade do carlos machado que lincon
99 pessoas notáveis no mundo todo e são
negras que são criadores e inventores e
pessoas de tecnologia e nós temos desde
a primeira pessoa no mundo a ser
caracterizada como médica e também nós
temos a professora sônia guimarães que é
uma professora que está hoje no
instituto de tecnologia da aeronáutica e
ela é brasileira
além disso esse livro também traz o cof
ana que faleceu hoje
então o quanto que nós temos pessoas
notáveis e que acabam não sendo
representa
e isso pra mim foi um potencial tão
grande para desenvolver outras ações
pensando nesse processo e com isso eu
acabei criando blackhawks e hoje é uma
iniciativa que incentiva a população
negra acessar o ecossistema de inovação
tecnologia startup eu entendi que cada
vez mais que a gente tenha uma
representação positiva do nosso processo
das pessoas dos empreendedores dos
produtos e serviços que a gente compra
maior é a nossa autoestima maior o
potencial que nós temos maior ão a
desenvoltura que a gente oferece e isso
acaba trazendo um potencial de cada vez
mais ter mais pessoas se sentindo
autorizadas até mesmo de realizar suas
ações
a gente acabou impactando mais 500
pessoas durante dois anos
isso pra mim é muito significativo
porque não é só o meu incômodo pessoal
eu entendi que através do meu incômodo
eu poderia apoiar outras pessoas e essas
pessoas se viam representadas por mim e
também pelos que estavam participando
das ações ea captada vez mais se sentiu
empoderadas para desenvolver suas
atividades
isso hoje blackhawks ele realiza
melhorias capacitações a gente faz
encontros ou pensando e desenvolvendo
negócios única e exclusivamente pensando
em negócios porque o nosso objetivo é
estampar também nas revistas e jornais
que nós também falamos sobre negócios
que nós também desenvolvemos ações
isso pra gente é muito significativo
porque cada vez mais a gente vai vendo
que tem outras pessoas que estão
desenvolvendo da diversas tecnologias
hoje nós temos desde tecnologias mais
simples de inteligência artificial de
desenvolvimento de a a a china e lane
como também é completado com mais
complexas no sentido de desenvolvimento
de produtos mais elaborados e se esse
propósito meu ele acabou agregando tanto
valor para outras pessoas que começou o
movimento de fato as pessoas começaram a
se identificar cada vez mais comprou
excesso de desenvolver seus produtos e
serviços e hoje não só pelo black hawks
mas tem outras iniciativas que acabam
desenvolvendo ações das mais diversas
isso pra mim é muito gratificante
entender que nós como população negra já
está inserido nesse ecossistema ainda
não em proporcionalidade mas uma
quantidade muito grande me fez cada vez
mais que a certeza de que é isso que eu
quero pra mim é dentro desse contexto
acabou que a gente teve muitas
possibilidades de encontrar pessoas que
queriam desenvolver mas o que nunca
atividades melhores então michel por
sinal foi uma pessoa aqui é me
acompanhou desde o começo e quis muito a
incentivar a o black hawks na existência
dele ou seja o compromisso não é só
nosso como população negra mas também de
outras pessoas que se identificam com a
causa de que cada um de nós aqui tem a
responsabilidade de fazer a mudança não
só pelo fato de se identificar como
aquele grupo mas também pelo fato de ver
que tem um potencial de apoiar essas
pessoas nesse processo
nesse processo é que acabou ganhando
diversos prêmios e por mais que eu seja
a pessoa que receba esses prêmios por
mais que eu seja a pessoa que está ali à
sé é sendo homenageado entre outras
coisas eu entendo que o que eu estou
fazendo representa um grupo diverso
representa um grupo tão grande que vai
promover com que essas pessoas elas não
só elas percebam que elas têm um
potencial mas também que a gente possa
provar para o mundo quanto que a gente
desenvolve ações de das melhores formas
e hoje da falta de braços que eu sentia
da não representação que eu não disse
que eu não tinha e eu não tinha hoje eu
já tenho uma maior possibilidade de me
ver representada dentro dos outros
grupos dentro de do ecossistema
entendendo que a gente tem várias
atividades que a gente pode fazer
durante todo o processo
então o compromisso que hoje eu tenho é
de desenvolver cada vez mais potenciais
pessoas para que elas acessem o
ecossistema
ovação tecnologia está a tap isso pra
mim significa que um só o contexto de
éter a representação da população negra
mas também saber que a gente está
desenvolvendo soluções que agregam valor
para todas as pessoas já que a gente é
maioria e já que a gente não está
representado nesses espaços
então o compromisso que eu gostaria de
deixar com vocês a reflexão que eu
gostaria de deixar com vocês
é como a gente pode fazer cada vez mais
para que eu não seja a única pessoa a
falar sobre a questão racial ou para que
eu não seja a única pessoa a desenvolver
ações voltadas para esse público que a
gente possa cada vez mais e mais ações
cada vez mais e mais atividades e que a
gente envolva pensando que é possível
juntar à tecnologia e inovação tap ao
mesmo tempo
obrigada
[Aplausos]